president Trump pretty expansive on the
possibility of that summit June 12th and
Singapore with North Korean leader Kim
jong-un
seeming to hope to get it back on track
as the North Koreans sent out a if you
will about military exercises with South
Korea this is president Trump have met
with the Vice Premier of China today
tweeting out a picture saying that that
meeting went well as China plays a
significant role obviously in all of
this plus the China trade negotiations
that are still continuing with that
let's bring in our panel jonathan swan
national political reporter for Axios
Abie Stoddard she is the associate
editor at RealClearPolitics and host of
No Labels radio on Sirius XM and Eli
Lake columnist for Bloomberg view okay
Jonathan what's the inner workings of
the White House think about the
possibilities of this summit June 12th I
heard Kellyanne conway saying you know
it could be delayed I think it's always
been an uneasiness and almost it was
everything was going too well for a
while you know Kim jong-un was released
the hostages and you know theatrically
destroying nuclear facility but john
bolton has always been the national
security adviser has always been very
very skeptical about even the notion of
donald trump going over there and
meeting with them so he's been through
this carousel before and he does not
trust the North Koreans has never had
faith in the idea that you can take them
at their word so I think he you have a
very very tough hardliner there with
john bolton who was talking to the
president every day and informing him
about the history and and the promises
that they've made before that being said
I'm told the president still wants to do
this he wants the the meeting face to
face and they're carrying on as if as if
nothing has changed
speaking of Bolton he was obviously
mentioned by the North Koreans in the
statement specifically he also told
Chris Wallace something that raised some
eyebrows and got some response take a
listen we have very much in mind the
Libya model from 2003 2004
there are obviously differences the
living
Graham was much smaller but that was
basically the agreement that we made and
so we'll want to test North Korea in
this first meeting for evidence that
they have made that strategic decision
the Libyan model isn't a model that we
have at all well we're thinking of North
Korea in Libya we decimated that country
so Amy I mean the Libyan model he's
talking about bold was talking about is
how they got rid of their weapons and
their their their ability to start down
that program not the actual end of
Muammar Qaddafi and how it all came to
an end but that's what the North Korean
see and that's what they're concerned
with and that's what President Trump was
referring to today once again speaking
from a different song book from someone
at the highest levels of his government
it's happened before and he actually
offered the North Korean leader some
protections today if he agrees to
denuclearize so look I do think that the
that the administration and particularly
the president is handling this in a very
shrewd way that whatever it is whether
it's saber-rattling or whatever Kim
jong-un is doing by canceling the talks
with the South Koreans threatening the
US and in create inserting all this
tension I think they've responded well
he the president said I'm trying to give
everyone the benefit of the doubt
they're obviously still trying to avert
war they're still trying to create a
discussion I bet John everything
Jonathan is saying is true about
Boldin's influence and sort of tempering
the president's expectations but I think
they're handling it the way needs to be
handled Kim jong-un cannot be trusted he
took those hostages to release them and
so far he has been way too acquiesce and
in its language to - for a long-standing
goal of that regime to be believable so
you know as the president says we'll see
but I think that they just need to try
to keep the prospect of this alive while
being cautious yeah
Eli well I would just say that I'm been
concerned about the North Korea outreach
for some time
but you know in the context of the China
part of this where it seems that you
know Trump is reversing himself on the
ZTE sanctions and this is after a long
and rigorous and legal process I just
think that all of this is sending the
wrong signal at this point you know we
the United States sets certain norms
particularly when it comes to issues of
nuclear proliferation and things like
that the Libya model is basically
getting rid of your nuclear program
isn't that what we're talking about when
the North Koreans talk about
denuclearization they talk they what
they mean is breaking the u.s. South
Korea alliance so if we don't have
clarification at this point on it then I
don't really have a lot of optimism for
these talks as much as I think it's
admirable the president is at least
trying and I would hope that he can use
the fact that someone like John Bolton
is his national security adviser as a
bit of leverage and perhaps to
intimidate a you know a tyrant like kim
jeong-hoon but this is this should be
very troubling of course the Libya model
is what we're seeking we want to get rid
of their nuclear program what else so
they're supposed to be talking about
yeah you know in the in the campaign we
did candidate casino I don't have a
fancy graphic but let's do summit Casino
you've got $100 and chips here and a
hundred is there it's moving forward
definitely June 12th and Singapore zero
is it's it's dead in the water so where
are your chips down the road Jonathan
probably 60 I'm going 75 I think the
date could change but I think it's gonna
happen because Kim Jungman wants it to
happen maybe like I don't know like you
know the point is to talk about
denuclearization then why even have the
summit to begin with it just confers
undue legitimacy on this thug have some
courage night all right there you go
two green chips on either side I got you
Eli